[Applaudissements]
allô mon chéri doux d'amour comment ça
va mon chéri comment ça va mon Francky
d'amour tu es tout beau là ça va ouais
super j'ai passé une super vacances là
je suis avec toute l'équipe et je
t'avoue qu'on est quand même un peu
inquiet pourquoi on a l'impression que
le champion de paddle a pris le dessus
sur l'animateur producteur tu vas pas
nous lâcher mais pas du tout mon bébé
t'inquiète pas le paddle c'est le
weekend la semaine je suis là c'est
boulot boulot on aime bien Castaldi
ah je sais ouais on comprend pas tout ce
qu'il dit on voit pas tout ce qu'il voit
on sait rien de ce qu'il fait on le sait
bon tu nous rassure c'est moi et bien
moi d'ailleurs là on répète et ça va
être la folie mon bébé bonne année
mon bébé
allez
bon
moi toute façon je suis d'accord avec
Géraldine en fait
je suis quand même d'accord avec
Géraldine ok c'est très bien Jean-Mi toi
écoute Cyril j'ai une année pour
réfléchir j'ai bien compris que pour
avoir sa place autour de cette table
c'était boulot boulot voilà regardez un
cul
[Rires]
ce soir notre invité ce soir c'est Eva
Longoria applaudissement pour toi
[Applaudissements]
tu vas dégager ok merci allez bonne tu
peux déjà plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]